da halten wir also fest viele menschen
haben wirkliche angst vom biber winter
was wenn die energiespeicher in
deutschland nicht mehr ausreichen damit
allen hier warm ist damit wir jeden tag
an einem funktionierenden herd kochen
können wird genug kraftstoff da sein und
mit dem auto zur arbeit zu fahren der
die menschen die suche nach lösungen und
schauen dabei natürlich auf die politik
und wo schaut dienen in die komplett
andere richtung schauen sie mal was wir
von bild exklusiv aufgedeckt haben
politiker haben dieser tage viele gut
gemeinte ratschläge ans volk wie energie
zu sparen ist kochen nur noch mit deckel
duschkopf wechseln heizung neu justieren
weniger auto fahren kurzum gürtel enger
wladimir putins krieg in der ukraine
macht energiemangel im herbst
wahrscheinlich aber müssen unsere
volksvertreter nicht gerade jetzt mit
gutem beispiel vorangehen tja das
gegenteil ist der fall bild hat über
wochen im deutschen bundestag
recherchiert und herausgefunden
alle lampen sind eingeschaltet auch am
helllichten tag die klimaanlage kühlt
auf angenehme 22 grad herunter und
fahrstühle rolltreppen und beförderungs
bänder sind im vollbetrieb dort die
spitze des eisbergs es ist praktisch
niemand im gebäude während der
sommerpause die politiker halten sich
also nicht unbedingt in ihre eigenen
regeln verschwenden energie in
rekordhöhe auf bild anfrage meint ein
sprecher sparen könne man nur nach und
nach durch schrittweise
außerbetriebsetzung über drei wochen
soll das einführen von maßnahmen noch
dauern und das obwohl
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck schon
ende juni die deutschen an wie es
schnell energie zu sparen bild fragte
wie lange dauert es hier das licht
auszuschalten antwort aus dem bundestag
ganze drei wochen noch und das 2
der unglaublich darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit unserem bild politik chef
jan schäfer schönen guten morgen jan
morgen wie kann das sein drei wochen
braucht der bundestag um dort das licht
auszuschalten haben die keine normalen
lichtschalter ich kann die frage leider
auch nicht beantworten weil ich sie mir
genauso stelle wie kann das eigentlich
sein was wir hier sehen ist eigentlich
ein rückfall in klassischen an
klassischen obrigkeitsstaat den wir aus
vergangenen jahrhunderten canon 1
startet etwas anordnet seinen bürgern
empfiehlt rät vorschreibt aber sich
selbst an die eigenen regeln nicht hält
wir müssen 1 bedenken zum einen ist der
bundestag seit drei wochen leer also
gerade das bundestagsgebäude der
reichstag ist seit drei wochen leer dort
finden in der sommerpause bisher keine
sitzungen statt das heißt er wird seit
drei wochen ein gebäude ein sehr sehr
großes gebäude massiv herunter gekühlt
auf einen wert von 22 grad denen sich
der bundestag selbst gar nicht mehr
gegeben hat das muss man ja noch
bedenken der dass das gremium in dem die
verdienten alten abgeordneten sitzen die
haben beschlossen dass der bundestag
wenn es warm ist nur noch
heruntergekühlt werden soll auf 24 bis
26 grad das heißt um energie zu sparen
hat man gesagt wir wollen gar nicht mehr
so runterkühlen wie das bisher der fall
war und bisher ist nichts passiert also
der ältestenrat das votum des
ältestenrates auch das wird missachtet
und das ist skandalös also eine typische
doppelmoral würde man meinen kann man
europas habe eigentlich noch ernst
nehmen mit seinen warnungen
robert habeck hat jetzt in dem konkreten
fall was das thema bundestag angeht
nichts damit zu tun dass liegt dann bei
der bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
das ist immerhin die zweithöchste
personen hier im staat aber er ist
derjenige der immer wieder sage ich
darin sparen und jetzt bitte schon
anfang das stimmt er hat in sein
ministerium ja beispielsweise sein
ministerium gesagt dass nur noch bis 26
grad heruntergekühlt werden darf er hat
verschiedene pläne entwickelt er
beglückt die deutschen ja auch permanent
mit irgendwelchen spar tipps und die
frage die du stellst ist vollkommen
richtig kann man das noch ernst nehmen
bei robert habeck vielleicht noch mit am
ehesten auf der anderen seite glaube ich
dass es millionen deutsche gibt die
ohnehin seit jahren sparen seit jahren
darauf achten möglichst wenig energie zu
verbrauchen denken nur daran dass der
strompreis in deutschland ja schon seit
jahren einer der höchsten wenn ich sogar
der höchste in europa ist das heißt da
gibt es ohnehin ganz ganz viel druck
dass man sich sehr energiesparend
verhält und da wirken diese appelle aus
der politik auch von robert habeck
natürlich für viele wie hohen die wissen
gar nicht mehr wo sie noch einsparen
sollen und umso befremdlicher und umso
skandalöser ist wenn wir nach berlin
schauen dass eigentlich in berlin man
den ahnung hat das was gefordert wird
und was den bürgern eingebremst wird das
setzt man selbst nicht um und wenn man
es umsetzt dann dauert das wochen das
kann nicht sein vielen dank jan schäfer
bild politikchef
[Musik]